future mobility and smart Mobility um
includes all types of Mobility um starts
with uh what we know today C in Israel
with buses but they can be electric
buses and more sophisticated ones they
could be autonomous vehicles um electric
cars but also softer Mobility options
like scooters bikes uh and other um
micro Mobility options that we see on
the street um I think that what what
leads this um industry is the fact that
we want to Grant people uh with the
freedom to choose whatever the mode they
uh prefer sometimes it could be two
types of Mobility the same day um and
just provide Alternatives so you can uh
have the freedom to to mobile from one
place to another and fulfill your uh
objectives either work hobbies and uh
just to to get access to
[Music]
Opportunities run
yes welcome to 20 minute leaders thank
you so much for joining me from Tel Aviv
how are you great great thank you for
having me here awesome to have you here
H you know this is a this show is all
about you know Innovation future
thinking entrepreneurship and Leadership
and ER I think that uh one of the most
uh amazing Transformations we've been
seeing is the future of mobility and how
we get around and how we transport um
and so to today you're the country
manager and CEO of bird Israel and and
you're H really the Forefront of looking
at what is what is the feature of
Mobility looking like in urban areas and
so I'm really looking forward to hearing
both about what this means to you today
but also sort of your own progression
into this role and how this H shapes up
to be something that you um that you're
choosing to dedicate your time to and uh
and obviously touching a little bit on
the also where we're headed in terms of
in terms of Mobility looking ahead and
so so without further Ado ran tell me a
little bit about this this world of of
feature mobility and what do this
actually include sure so I think future
mobility and smart Mobility um includes
all types of Mobility um it starts with
uh what what we know today CL in Israel
with buses but they can be electric
buses and more sophisticated ones they
could be autonomous vehicles um electric
cars but also softer Mobility options
like scooters bikes uh and other um
micro Mobility options that we see on
the street um I think that what what
leads this um industry is the fact that
we want to Grant people uh with the
freedom to choose whatever the mode they
uh prefer sometimes it could be two
types of Mobility the same day um and
just provide Alternatives so you can uh
have the freedom to to mobile from one
place to another and fulfill your uh
objectives either work hobbies and uh
just to to get access to
Opportunities so so what's changed why
essentially is traditional Mobility just
not good enough anymore I think we all
understood that cars are not good
anymore um the infrastructure is limited
we have limited space of uh to build
buildings we have limited space for
water we also have a limited space with
uh um lands so the population is growing
we have more cars um but we're stuck and
our day is also limited we have only 24
hours so every year we spend more hours
on uh on traffic congestion and people
understood governments understood that
we should change it so we need to allow
more people to move at any given point
uh it's called like Mass uh
Transportation um but also we need to um
allow them lighter options so I think
the recent decade at least in Israel um
is the understanding of okay we're the
most congested um country in the OCD um
we're going to spend at least two more
hours within the next uh um 10 years in
traffic we need to solve it we didn't do
it like European countries um decad ago
so now we need to start and we try to
collect more and more Transportation
models like scooters uh but other other
Transportation options as well and and
so what is it that other countries
adopted a few a few decades ago that we
didn't um I think uh the the the most
common thing is the Metro uh Metro
System that you come to a European
capital or even uh lat cities you just
is the Metro or light Trails um very
rarely buses but still uh you have some
uh in Israel all the transportation is
based on uh heavy train and buses so we
all know the works about on the of the
light rail it will take let's say 10
more years and the Metro will take 20
more years M um and until then and
especially with the fact that we don't
have public transportation on weekends
um this is the main reason that uh we
need more Alternatives than that um
let's say uh solving the congestion and
unlock ourselves and unlock new ways to
move around got it okay and so tell me a
little bit about the the the experience
of of scoters as a form of Mobility so
this is something that now I think I
think by now probably every listener and
every viewer here has experienced
experienced um either bird Scooters or
or any or any other form of scooters on
their own but what do these scooters
effectively represent sort of what are
they what are the what is sort of the
thesis behind them and and maybe even
talk a little bit about sort of the the
way that they're built or what they're
trying to accomplish in their current
user experience great so I think um what
we see in Israel at least is amazing the
adoption rates are are numerous and and
multiplies other countries by by a law
um Israel is are early adoped so we had
micr Mobility options even electric ones
before the Shir scooters companies enter
thisel um we use we use them uh as
private scooters um because people
understood that they have to move around
and they need to get to work and they
can be leged just because their bus
didn't arrive or they're staying on
traffic and don't find any parking so we
did have some but in 2018 when bird
entered Israel um it was as soft as we
imagine it today because we can't
imagine the city and all the nearby
cities without it because we have a good
weather um at at the end of the day
Israel and the center of Israel are very
small
and I think it allows you uh um the the
option to be free uh you just ride on
scooter you use your Mobile app you
didn't think you can do such thing you
just use your Mobile app and then that's
it you're moving with 25 kilom to hour
you can get to the other um side of the
city within 10 15 minutes um yeah
however this comes with operational um
challenges right and what at the
beginning uh we used off the shelf um
off the shelf scooter because what we
wanted to prove is that the concept is
work we wanted an MVP to see okay we use
we deploy some vehicles in telev will
people use them and they did but these
were not adopted to mass uh usage and
let's say 10 15 times a day um of course
it's not uh the the private asset of
people so when you list something maybe
not not necessarily but you treat it a
bit differently right weights are
different they variz from one person to
another so we had to develop our own
School ERS they're M much more heavier
um they're adopted to um uh many people
writing them may the same time but every
uh every day and also we have operators
that uh pick them up charging them M um
maintaining them we had to make them
very easy to repair so we will'll reduce
labor cost and spare parts cost
essentially these are the um um most of
the coast most of the casts labor and uh
spare parts so we had to build something
that is very um is fit to share the
writing and I think today what we see is
for for each one of the companies by the
way is like the fourth generation um
after many Engineers um some from the
airspace uh industry uh and the car
industry thoughts and and uh resources
on developing these vehicles and now we
see totally different vehicle it's
basically a computer with a brand that
can now um um use us and The Regulators
the cities um to use more Advanced
Technologies regarding Gil fencing and
slowing down the vehicle uh accurate
parking Etc so it's not just uh a
scooter electric scooter that you can
ride um it's basically a computer um
that can also Implement regulation and
policies and and there's a whole
ecosystem around the charging right so
the way that you're the way that you're
creating an incentive system for how to
keep these scooters operational by the
way just for context what in numbers
what where are we at so H how many
scooters do we even have in in Tel Aviv
right now so um B is around 5,000
Vehicles spread in 10 cities um so it's
not just Tel Aviv it's Tel Aviv R give
time even
so 5,000 scooters now I would imagine
that on average you probably have to
charge one at least every two days
unless okay and and so that's a lot of
operations like I guess you don't have
bird employees running around on
scooters trying going in charging with a
helmet with a helmet how H how do you go
about getting all of these to charge
right so we have a massive this is part
of our job uh to set uh op operations
correctly operation Excellence um is is
what we care about so we have our own um
data metrics that can support the
establishment of such system and then at
the end of the day you need vendors
operators to do it so contractors um
vendors that we um ask them either to
charge either to rebalance either to
move either to uh repair um everything
is Task based so you get it's a paper
task you see the operations on the map
you get the vehicle everything is
monitored and then you do what we asked
you to do you do it properly and then
you deploy the vehicle back um however
this doesn't replace the safety
measurements that we take and we use our
own in-house uh mechanics and we Monitor
and quality check uh of the vehicle is
very important for us so either way we
meet the vehicle um every uh here and
then um these are uh more confidential
numbers but we use to repair and
maintenance uh and preserve the safety
of the vehicle very often but regardless
the charging and the rebalancing of the
vehicle s so it sounds like it's not
that the what you're alluding to is that
part of the sort of I guess the
operational excellence or your ability
to to operate something at such a scale
it's also your ability to be very data
driven as a company so your ability to
understand and you know what needs
charging when what needs rebalancing and
then how do you then go and and automate
a lot of that process with vendors sure
I think I think this is the process
those companies had uh within the years
at the beginning it was proving the
concept then it was all about scale and
proving cities that it's possible but we
all know the the stories of the
companies uh money
today is a bit more expensive than it
was and today the the buzzword and and
what we care about is margins um we need
to make our operations be as cost
effective as we can uh and this is part
of the job data driven monitoring and
pushing our margins to be better every
day every month and at the end of the
day be profitable we need right to
finance uh we need to finance uh uh new
vehicles every every time every together
are becoming a bit bigger so it used to
we used to have a new vehicle a new
title vehicle every six months one year
now it happens every two three years I
guess um the the the gaps will only be
bigger but still um this is something
that companies need to finance um and we
generate our money from rights so uh
this is why we care about margins and
this is part of the job the p&l uh
monitoring understanding all the metrics
and at the end of the day
how uh every action that we do as a
company um is reflected in the unit
economics tell me a little bit about
your own Journey so you're obviously you
care a lot about the space you've you've
been in the future of Mobility since
before bird um what is sort of your
relationship uh to this future of
Mobility how did it get started and and
why is this something that you're so
passionate about so I think um it's a
very good question I think all all
journey I had is uh uh consisted within
my current FL um I was passionate about
Transportation um I think since I was
young I always told people yeah I I'll
be Ministry of Transportation one day um
because I think I I you know I I used to
live in estana this is where I grown up
at I'm uh used to come a lot to Tel Aviv
um right with buses uh I was moving all
the time and I appreciate like how the
quality of transportation makes you feel
um more free
so I think I really like this uh
industry um then during uh my studies uh
um of economy and and block I work at
IBM so there I developed a bit my tech
Sav and the approach towards uh
Technologies um and the if I can add to
that the legal uh knowledge that I have
I'm also an attorney but I didn't work
as uh as one and the numbers um the
economy uh behind those uh Industries um
brought me to a stage that future
Mobility really interests me and I think
I can contribute a lot I started in uh
future Mobility with an NGO dealing with
smart Mobility uh basically we said it
with implementing the the technologies
that we develop here in Israel as the
startup Nation um we can solve the
congestion of Israel we're good with
exporting but let's implement it though
there are regulatory barriers so we help
um government the the government and
companies to overcome those regulatory
barriers and by the way so when you and
when you were in that position was was E
Scooters and the and the adoption and
implementation of third party scooters
in in Israel was that a part of the of a
larger understanding that this is
something that will be potential
mitigation exactly and I think um one of
the um one of the topics we dealt with
was the implementation of helmets um in
Israel and it's it's a great um use case
of uh safety uh regulation the city of
Tel required a helmet but also very
operational and cost uh um heavy
purchasing and developing even the the
lock it was like think uh um think that
we we were at the beginning of this
industry like just uh two years and then
uh the new seat belt was invented a
helmet um and then we helped the the
companies with Tel Aviv municipality it
was during covid times um it could if if
not implemented correctly um it might it
could be the end of shed scooters in
Israel um Tel CD understood how heavy it
is they postpone it um within a year and
I think it proved itself um it led the
companies at some time to develop more
um sustainable uh locks and sustainable
helmets and today work at the street and
we see plenty of helmets and we see
people using that I think this uh
intervention of uh regulatory knowledge
as well um um helped the companies and I
think these were my um first steps with
the E scooter uh industry and then it
was very um very native that I would
natural that I would move on to one of
these uh companies um at least to lead
the policy and government partnership
side um it also includes a lot of uh
request for proposal rfps the um mlus so
then I started my first step very before
becoming the um country manager in C
amazing where are we heading do you
think so if if we look at at congested
cities five years down the line or 10
years down the line are are East
scooters the solution are they a sort of
a a a path towards a solution where
where what world are you envisioning in
terms of future
Mobility um so we we tend to said it we
a uh first Last Mile solution but in
Israel we not just uh first Last Mile
solution we're also the A2B uh people
just use us as the their favorite um
option um I think that what we will see
more is more investment first in
infrastructure yeah we need public
transportation Lanes public bike Lanes
um and it's proven when you have uh bike
lines people ride more they feel more
safe and if you ask people why didn't
why they not ride SCS they will tell you
probably safety so if you solve the
safety problem and you um and you just
have the safer B CL people will use it
more uh so it starts with infrastructure
and then I think um
the uh it's it's all about what you
teach people when they're young so if
you teach people that they should use
cars eventually this is what they do but
if you start very young to use the bus
use the light Trail um you know if if uh
young kids will ride uh will use the
light Trail apparently when they will be
20 30 and they need to commute to their
work yeah it will be just natural AB I
think every year uh the mode split and
as a country we need to monitor it as
well do we take people from the private
cars and move them to other alternative
um as long as we had goals and targets I
think we'll get there uh and yes shirt
scooters will be there as a a massive
alternative I think we growing our
Market sh as companies um both from uh
the entire ridership and also from other
uh mtit it's just growing every year and
it's not the only solution and we also
respect um inter mobility and the use of
bus and then a scooter um the the
mobility as a service uh will just get
bigger we're we're changing from owning
cars to use cars but just as an
alternative so also autot share all the
the other Alternatives will be there um
but it will take time and I think our um
politicians Regulators have the the
power to to say whether it will be
within 10 years for 20 years enforcement
is important and the investment and
resources in the infrastructure so um
it's an ecosystem it's not just the
companies it's not just the private
sector it's also U the public sector and
the officials and
politician Ron thank you so much for
taking the me um as a somebody who's
experienced a lot of the transformation
myself here in our city it's a I can
definitely attest to how how awesome it
was to see specifically you know the the
the way in which the evolution that
you're talking to I I distinctly
remember the the F the older generation
of you know right the the very first
scooters that came into Tel Aviv from
bird and then the the evolution into the
heavier scooters and the doubling down
on the helmets and and the entire sort
of ecosystem here sort of upgrading and
transitioning to this new this new
thinking model um and so I I very very
much appreciate having experienced much
of that trans information and I'm very
excited about about what's coming up so
thank you again for for taking the time
to talk with me and H and I'm excited to
continue saying where where you grow was
really fun thanks you for everything
you're doing